hello everyone and welcome to the 1960
World Chess Championship match between
Mikhail Botvinnik and the Michael Todd
this is game 11 and if you remember from
my previous videos towel actually had a
three point lead in this match after
Game seven and then he and his trainer
Alexander Collins had this crazy idea
that Tosh should start playing crazy and
if he wins one more game that will be
enough for him to actually win this
match but then he lost in game eight he
lost in game nine and in my previous
video in game ten you've seen that
amazing game that both botany can tell
played extremely well that game ended in
a draw so Todd was able to stop the
bleeding and I would like to invite you
to to observe this quote above the board
Emmanuel Lasker resigned his match with
kappa blanka when there was still 10
games left this is something nickel tal
talks about prior to this game it's not
that Lasker wouldn't be able to maybe
win those four games it was just that a
cup of Blanca was feeling so confident
that he was he was simply playing chess
that was too good so Alaska thought that
it wasn't even worth wasting his time
and this is something tal also talks
about since that was three points in the
lead he thought maybe if I get a four
point lead then that will be like
extremely hard to overcome from both
Finnick but but he just played it cool
he was three points down but it was
actually tal who lashed out and it was
tall who lost his nerves so then he lost
two games now it's now the result is
only one point lead for Michael Tao and
here before this game Alexandre Koblenz
actually gave a very valuable piece of
advice to tall he told him don't try
don't challenge Botvinnik to a caro-kann
anymore you will have your entire life
to review to the caro-kann as a defense
but you're here just to win this match
so so maybe maybe you could try
something else and tell really enjoyed
this idea so he didn't want to didn't
want to gain any kind of real opening
advantage straight out of the opening he
just wanted an opening that will create
the most complicated position possible
to allow to allow for some you know
chances on both sides so for the first
move in this game this is game
all of the previous games Stahl started
with E for here tile opened with Knight
to f3
so the reti opening knife to f6 g3 and
the g6 and the botanique was never known
to go for the Kings Indian defense his
main idea with Knight to f6 and G sexist
maybe transposing to the groom fold
Bishop to g2 Bishop to g7 we have
castles castles by botanique c4 c6 and
here top plate b3 tell didn't like the
idea of going d4 because then botany can
very easily go into this symmetrical
position with d5 and now after white
develops he can always play this Knight
to e4 move and this is a nice position
for black easily easily equalized
so after c6 he played b3 you know he
wants to create everything on the board
keep everything on the board
try to keep it as complicated as
possible but Botvinnik immediately goes
for this nice to e4 move opening up an
attack from the bishop to the rook on a1
and basically forcing it out to push d4
so talvez plate we have d4 and now
between goes d5 but it's not really the
same position as the one tile tried to
avoid this was the position I'll try to
avoid the now this pawn is still on b2
and the knight is occupying the D 2
square now this is the position from the
game at where the point is actually on
me tree and this pawn is 22 note I will
develop the bishop here so called it
play d4 we have b5 Bishop to b2 and now
Bishop to e6 tau
doesn't he doesn't think it's a bad move
this Bishop to e6 but he says that black
will have to spend a lot of time for
every move it it creates a very hard
position for black and it doesn't it he
doesn't think this was the best idea for
botanique but ok Knight B to d2
we have Knight captures and now Quinn
capture sandy - and it was a this was a
very important decision by screen
capture sandy - if you play Knight
capture sandy - which seems like it
could be a reasonable move you're
protecting the c4 pawn twice you open up
your own light square bishop here the
problem is a black has this immediate
counter with c5 now your D pawn is under
attack you can't capture of course
because your bishop on b2 is undefended
and after C captures and Bishop captures
and E for Bishop to c6 you can never
push d5 again your Bishop is undefended
here so after you play Knight to f3 now
we have captures captures captures and
after Knight captures Queen to b6 and
black has a decent game there's really
nothing to worry about here so a very
important decision here so tall of
course played Queen captures on d2 he
doesn't allow any complications like
this Knight to a6 and black pretty much
developed all of his pieces it is a
pretty weird square for the knight but
you know if it works why not
rook 8 to c1 now I'm defending the c4
pawn queen to d6 and now Knight to e5
and this is an excellent square for the
knight black will have a very hard time
getting rid of it from e5 you don't
really want to play a move like f6 after
night comes to d3 then your pawn
structure is a bit weird around the King
you locked your dark square Bishop in
like this and black no longer has any
pressure on the d4 square so no problems
here for white so after Knight to e5
rook F to D 8 we have rook F to D 1 and
now rook a to c8 now all of the pieces
are developed and it's time to create a
game plan here at all did consider
starting a pawn storm on the Queen side
starting with the move c5 and after
Queen to b8 push b4 and then maybe
prepare a 4 B 5 and so on and so on but
here in this position he actually did
like f6 for black and after Knight
retreats now Bishop to a5 and black does
gain a lot of activity here this Bishop
is actually posted on a nice square and
the black will be ready to push a 5 here
opening up the position so after this
rook 8 the c 8 tall played Queen to a5
and this is an excellent move and it's
an excellent score for the Queen
although it was a bit more centralized
done d2 here the Queen kind of prevents
this Knight from moving as the a7 pawn
would be under attack you can't kick
away the queen with b6 then the knight
would fall so here botany plate D
captures on c4 there is an interesting
line and I will show it because you know
it's it's quite an interesting line what
would happen if Knight to see Sir
was played here so can black actually
sacrifice the spawn which the idea of
maybe capturing the Queen
well if Queen captures then of course
rook attacks Queen Queen to b6 rook
attacks Queen on a6 Queen has to capture
the b7 pawn but now comes the ship to c8
again attacking the Queen Queen goes to
be 8 and now rook to 8 again attacking
the Queen Queen goes to b6 and now rook
to a6 and what do you do here is this
like a forced draw for black not really
because a white has c5 this is the
problem now I have to rope captures pawn
captures and rook captures white was
simply play III and after all is said
and done a white actually wanna pawn and
he doesn't have much to show for it
black doesn't really have much to show
for so botanic not interested in any of
this
after this Queen to a5 move he plays D
captures on c4 we have Knight captures
on c4 not be captures on c4 this does
seem to improve your pawn structure but
then what we can simply exchange Queens
with Queen to before that tall doesn't
like this so Knight captures on c4 and
here Queen to c7 again offering a trade
of Queens and here tall does table is
like Queen captures on c7 Knight
captures and nice to a5 simply hemming
in on this b7 pawn and this c6 pawn as
the knight and Bishop are now really
controlling this Queen side but he
thinks white can do much better than
this so after Queen c7 he actually goes
all the way to a 1 with the Queen and
this is he says this is the best Square
for the Queen she's not on c3 to be
bothered by this bishop she's not on d2
to be butter maybe but rook from the 8th
she's only one and she's perfectly saved
there waiting for her opportunity to get
back into the game and here botanique
goes Queen to b8 getting the Queen out
at the C file I move like Bishop
captures on c4 was possible with the
idea that after rook captures and now
black does have the c5 move and yes it's
true your Bishop unbe 2 is still
undefended you did play the fringe c5
move but white was simply ignore you now
efore and you can't really do anything
with the C pawn since your queen is on e
on c7
and after I move like b5 the rook moves
still like really doesn't have anything
here 6.now e5 comes and only problems
for black here
so after Queen e1 first bought in each
place
Queen to b8 now he does have some ideas
of executing c5 tal now pushes efore and
now this is another useful thing of
having the Queen only one you she
supports d4 pawn and now rook Bishop
captures on c4 here rook captures on c4
big afters on c4 again would be met by
c5 so rook captures on c4 and now Knight
to c7 here Bishop to h3 attacking that
that rook we have e 6 and now Bishop to
c1 which the idea that this Bishop is
definitely coming to a 4 at some point
especially if botanique will immediately
want to play something like night to b5
to bring the knight over to d6 and then
the bishop on f4 would be extremely
useful as it comes there would attempt
on the Queen and b8 so Queen to a8 and
again a weird square for the Queen but
tau agrees with Botvinnik this is the
best Square for the Queen Bishop to g5
now attacking the rook rook to e8 and
now Queen to d2 with some ideas of
Bishop to h6 maybe exchanging this dark
square bishop and also solid a gaining
more protection of the d4 pawn and now
botanique plays f5 and here tal spent a
lot of time as this f5 move really
really gives a lot to black and tal
definitely agrees this is the best move
and he did consider a lot of things for
example if you push a 5 you you simply
allow this night to get this d5 square
and it's an excellent square for the
knight white doesn't really have
anything here
another thing after f5 told it consider
f3 maybe to improve his position in the
center but then tonight to b5 the night
is coming to d6
from there he will attack the rookin see
for this knight on e4 this opponent b4
twice and again if you prevented by
playing a 5 so now the knight can come
to c6 to d6
and now the knight will once again
return to c7 and then
have the d5 square available for him
again
and another thing here there was the
idea of actually playing he captures on
f5 later after the game some of the
commentators said that maybe this was
the winning idea for tall but it really
wasn't because after it captures an i-5
and he captures an f5 now g4 was the
main idea but now F captor son G for
Bishop captures on g4 and now black can
actually play Knight to d5 and sacrifice
the exchange here and after Bishop
captures Queen captures with with this
powerful knight on d5 and white without
having a light square Bishop the black
definitely has at least compensation
here so after this f5 move we have
Bishop to h6 now of course that wants to
exchange this strong dark square bishop
we have Bishop captures Queen captures
and now rook to e7 rook to e1 and here
rook to f8 top plays rook the c5 with
the idea of bringing the rook all the
way to e5 to exert even more pressure
here and on the e-file so that when it
captures an f5 happens he will have
doubled rooks on the e-file Queen to d8
and here top played rope to e5 and the
botanique was in severe time trouble
here this is only move 27 and he still
has to make 13 moves to reach time
control and he he's not interested in
Queen captures on d4 he he played rook
to g7 but tile actually thought that
Queen captures on d4 is actually a force
to draw for black wood the idea that
after it captures capture steer now
Bishop captures on f5 you can't capture
because your rope would hang on e7 now
rook to f7 now there's there's a triple
attack on the bishop here but now rook
to e5 getting the rope out of the way
with attacking the Queen Queen to f6 now
and now Queen captures rook captures
Bishop captures with Czech Knight
captures rook captures rook captures on
f2 and here you have an endgame four
pawns each two rooks each and that's a
completely drawn endgame so it's hard to
say didn't really know if both Winnick
decided and not to go for this because
he didn't calculate the line all the way
to a draw or because both eunuch
maybe wanted to actually still play this
game and go for a win
so here rock to g7 was played and this
is a weird move not because it's a weird
move but because in Intel's book the
move is actually rook to f7 but on the
official chess games.com database where
I take the pigeons for the games it's
actually rook to g7 but the reason it
doesn't matter because both both moves
lead to the same position so it's hard
to say which move was really played
probably the one from tiles book but
again maybe it's just a bad copy of the
book so hard to say but it doesn't
matter okay rook to g7 and here top
played Queen back to d2 he decided it
was time to defend the d4 pawn now
because with this rook move now
botanique is actually preparing to
capture this pawn so tall defended it
Queen to d2 and now we have Queen to d6
Bishop back to f1 as there's really no
point in having the bishop on h3 anymore
now towel is preparing to bring it all
the way to c4 rook back to d7 and now
from this position it's totally the same
there was that move rook f7 or rope g7
he captures on f5 rook captures on f5
and rook 5 2 e for capturing the rook
Tull agrees that maybe capturing the
rook was the way to go for white but he
decided for this move and here a botanic
played a rook to f6 which is again a
weird move because it seems once again
for some reason whether it's severe time
trouble or the fact that both eunuch
still wants to play this game for a win
decides not to go for rook to d5 because
I have to look to d5 there was like a
there's not a triple attack on the deep
on c5 is coming and the only move for
tal is basically to go Bishop to c4
which for which forces the draw after
rook captures Queen captures Queen
captures rook captures rook captures
Bishop captures with Czech Knight
captures rook captures King to f7
attacking the rook and rook to e2 not
allowing the black group to enter the
second rank five points each one Rock
each it's a drawn endgame so for some
reason this is
move thirty-one Botvinnik doesn't go for
this he plays rook to f6 and maybe he
thought that that it's the same idea
white can't really push for advantage
here
maybe Bishop to c4 well now that won't
really make sense because then simply
rook can block and four pieces are
defending this pawn so it's hard to say
did botanique really refuse the draw
here or does both Phoenix still want to
win this game either way he played rook
to f6 and here top played h4 would the
idea you know there's a pawn in g6 why
not attack it would point to h5 and here
again in time trouble botnik plays King
to g7 and Todd pushes h5 and tosses I
don't really have a plan here when I
push h5 I'm just gonna see what happens
maybe I'm gonna capture maybe but maybe
we'll play something then I will play
something maybe I will pull the pond all
the way to h6 and then maybe create
something there
he has no idea here but he's having no
idea plan actually works here because
botanique plays G captures on h5 which
kind of made his King g7 move futile the
idea of king to g7 is to actually defend
the g6 pawn went all this has to capture
with H captors and g6 but here in botany
kind of wait some with King to g7 and
then captures G captures on h5 kind of
ruining his pawn structure there and
Todd was rook to h4 not his idea is the
double rooks on the H file move Queen to
g5 check followed by rogue g6 and Queen
captures on h5 Todd doesn't really enjoy
this as Knight to d5 Zen is coming and
then blacks game becomes very active so
after this G captors and h5 look to h4
and now King back to g8 so botanique now
has to make rook room for the rook as
this Bishop is coming to d3 and after
rook captures here there there are going
to be some problems with the h7 pawn
Bishop to d3 rope to g7 now and rook to
e5 now simply not allowing both unique
any tactics now the rook is also
protecting the d4 pawn very nicely and
by blocking the Queen
tal doesn't really allow any rook
captures Angie
ideas in the future this move sorry this
move wouldn't be possible now because
after rook captures pawn captures and
queen capture simply Queen to g2 would
not allow black to capture the rook on
h4 as you know there's the King on g8
but you know it's useful rook to e5 this
rook is also now ready to come to the H
file so definitely a nice position rook
to f7 adding more defense to the h7 pawn
and now first Queen to h6 bringing even
a queen to the attack Queen to e7 and
now rook he captures on h5 so now for of
Tallis pieces well two rooks a bishop
and the Queen are eyeing the h7 point
here knife to d5 as there's a really no
danger of capturing here but knife the
d5 is the crucial defensive move here
because now Todd's idea doesn't work and
he spent a lot of time calculating
calculating it trying to make it work
but it simply doesn't work the idea was
Bishop captures on h7 and after rook
captures the rook to g4 check King to h8
and now Queen to g6 threatening Queen to
g8 checkmate and there's only one good
move here and the only defense here is
Knight to f6 after which White's doesn't
really have anything and this was the
importance of knights e7 to Knight to d5
move because now you can't really do
anything
rook captures rook captures and after
you attack this night simply Knight back
to d5
black is up a piece and winning this
game so when Tao saw this it was a very
nice move by but when he could this
Knight to d5 he retreated with the Queen
Queen to d2 and now he opens up the
attack to the H some important from the
rooks the Queen doesn't have to come
first Knight to f6 attacking the rook
rook to h6 and now Queen to d6 Queen to
d6
perhaps not the greatest move but this
is move 40 and the botanique had to make
it to reach time control so he did make
it
and now tal plays rook to f4 and this is
why why maybe tells the games are a bit
more interesting
you know then most at least to me he
plays f4 knowingly that
rook to f4 is not the best move but it's
the most complicated move and the
botanique now has to make a move that
will be used tomorrow so the game will
be adjourned after botanique makes a
move here and he wants to make the
position as complicated as possible he
now has two rooks attacking the knight
on f6 and Botvinnik has to decide what
to do here he has to make a move and you
know the position will be complicated so
botany doesn't really have an entire
night to analyze a simple position
so here botanique tomorrow when the
position was continued they saw that
Botvinnik played a queen to f8 and this
was ok simply defending the knight and
you know all is well
Queen to e3 now comes Knight to d5
attacking the Queen and the rook and now
Queen arrow chapters on f7 Queen
captures on f7 and now Queen to e5 and
this is probably the move both eunuch
missed in his home analysis and the
Whitehall enjoyed such a complicated
position probably motronic thought Queen
captures on e6 would was gonna be played
Queen captures rook captures rook to g4
attacking the pawn on d4 Bishop to c4
here and after King to f7 rook to h6 it
would be a better position for white but
certainly black can play this perhaps
even to a draw but here top played Queen
to e5 and it's a weird move but it all
really really does have ideas here so
what you play here is black first of all
you do have to make a move now none of
the moves really seemed that appealing
for example Queen Queen to be a Czech
would pick up the a7 pawn you do have to
play something so but only plays Knight
to c7 simply not allowing this and the
knight the c7 is the strongest engine
move so you can't really complain about
botanics move I mean he he did players
from this the angel move but in reality
it's simply it's simply owning position
for white and tall proves it very nicely
he plays Queen to c5 and this was the
idea
not going for exchanges in any endgame
where why does have the advantage but
simply the queenside
you know is free for grabs you know the
queen will pick up all of these pawns
so Queen to f3 and now comes Bishop
captures on h7 this was the problem
sorry this was the problem of creating
such a position because now if you if
you go something like Queen captures on
a 7 then you have rook to f7 and now
White is in a whole other problems here
there's the problem of capturing an f2
and also why the Bishop is attacked on
v3 so you'd have to you'd have to
protect DF to pawn or you have to make a
move like d5 and then black simply
simply captures the bishop and being a
piece down black is winning this game
but after Queen to have three tal found
Bishop captures on h7 rook captures on
h7 and now Queen to g5 and here black is
in trouble if you go rook to g7 blocking
you get Queen to d8 check and now if
King blocks simply Queen captures night
so you'd have to play Queen to f8 but
this really doesn't help you as a rock
to h8 wins the Queen King capture screen
Jefferson f8 you lose the Queen and the
game so after Queen g5 Botvinnik tried
Queen to a trade but it's no better
Queen to d8 to check and now you have to
go to the to the seventh rank with the
King King to g7 rook captures skin
captures and now Queen captures on c7
King moves and now Queen captures on b7
and after this little skirmish it all
started with Bishop captures on h7
tallies actually up two points and a
queen a queen opponent game being up two
pawns white is completely winning so
Queen to b4 here top plate Queen to a6
he doesn't want to grab the a 7-point as
he he's not sure if he will be able to
prevent all of the checks but with Queen
a sex he finds the idea we have Queen to
be one check a king moves now Queen to
e4 check King moves to f1 Queen B one
chef King G to Queen c2 check King of
three Queen f5 check King to e3 and now
Queen to g5 check King e2 Queen to h5
check King D 2 and now King
to have six there's no point in checking
anymore because at the king will be able
to hide behind the pawns and only now
Queen captures on c6 so now you're up
three points is white and it's only it's
only a matter of technique how you're
gonna in this game Queen to a5 check we
have Quinta see tree blocking giving up
the a to pawn but it doesn't matter
Queen captures came to e3 now the king
is now well protected King to f7 and now
the final finesse to finish this game is
d5 d5 simply with the idea of
temporarily sacrificing a pawn but this
will create a very nice past G and past
f1 which will which are connected pawns
so that's pretty much unstoppable
he captures on d5 we have a queen to c7
check King e6 Queen to c6 check King g7
and now pink after Sun b5 so grabbing
that sacrificed pawn queen to a one a
queen to e4 King to f7 King to f4 Queen
the c1 came to g4 Queen to a one now
Queen to d5 check King moves and now
King to f5 we have Queen to be one check
King to f6 and it was in this position
that Mikhail Botvinnik resigned the game
so game 11 went to Mikhail tal he's once
again two points in the lead and he
managed to grab a win by playing Knight
to f3 and the first move is white this
is huge for tall so now which to two
points in the lead and being confident
in his ability to create real
complications over the board and then
prevail in those in those complications
is is definitely what he needs to win
this match so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it
we're gonna pick up on this match as
soon as as soon as possible but you know
for the next two days I will be pretty
bit of pretty busy busy covering the
candidates but yeah I do hope you enjoy
this I would like to thank your cigar
rich Christian garbage Boris mark on
each given manna I just British ahed
Pete Marshall Rodney Christian and Paul
Gibbons for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon probably with a nice
game
from the candidates thank you